the project is called cities and human
society in the 21st century
and the logic is pretty simple without
800 million people will be added in
cities all over the world in the next
two decades or so and within twenty
twenty-five years we'll have 60 cities
over ten million inhabitants cities are
the leaders of our globalizing world and
they are the avant-garde of all this
transformation so we need to really take
care of them and to understand how to
deal with that these are places where
you have an immense concentration of
power wealth Allen cultural movement
innovation going on and then to think
about these four areas that make sense
for us climate change and the
post-carbon City big data and all the
new data and knowledge where we can
produce the social division inclusion of
cities and the infrastructure and
housing bringing people together from
different urban experiences and getting
them to talk to one another and getting
them to think about how the evidence
that I know from one setting might be
similar to but also might be different
from the evidence that comes from
another setting potentially a way also
of thinking outside the box and changing
what the box is so to do that you need
something like safar which is you look
in this capacity to provide a framework
when you bring those people from
different backgrounds together to think
about knowledge that might be
transformative and as a result the
impact will hopefully be that each of
the disciplines will become more
powerful by interacting with the other
discipline successful cities will make
for a successful 21st century human
society as a whole and that's really our
our goal in our deep commitment and to
do it at a planetary or global scale
[Music]